these were validly issued subpoenas
under the house rules the white house
argument to the contrary is wrong and it
would have profound negative
implications for how Congress and our
democracy function On January 9th 2019
the house adopted its rules like we do
every Congress and these rules gave the
committee the power to issue subpoenas
they're not ambiguous rules and here is
a relevant portion of rule 11 on slide
55 the houses standing rules give each
committee subpoena power for the purpose
of carrying out any of its functions and
duties as it considers necessary this
investigation began on September 9th
before the speaker's announcement on
September 24th that it would become part
of the impeachment inquiry umbrella the
president doesn't dispute that the
subpoenas issued by these committees
were fully within their respective
jurisdiction the argument is that
somehow by declaring that this
investigation also falls under an
inquiry to consider articles of
impeachment which gives Congress
actually greater authority that somehow
it nullifies the traditional oversight
Authority and this just doesn't make any
sense now the president counters that we
have to take a full vote on impeachment
first because that's what's been done in
the past and the Nixon inquiry however
the Judiciary Committee needed a house
resolution to delegate subpoena power
and that's different than the committee
standing rules today president actually
compels the opposite conclusion several
federal judges have been investigated in
peach and convicted in the Senate
without the house having ever taken in
an official vote to authorize the
inquiry and a federal court recently
confirmed there was no need for a formal
vote of the full house to commence
impeachment proceedings but even
assuming a house what was necessary
there was a vote the text of House
Resolution 662 clared that the six
investigate investigative committees of
the house were directed to continue
their ongoing investigations as part of
the existing House of Representatives
inquiry and whether
were sufficient grounds for the House of
Representatives to exercise its
constitutional power to impeach and the
committee report which accompanies a
resolution specifically described the
subpoenas that had been issued by the
investigating committees and said quote
all subpoenas to the executive branch
remain in full force so why didn't the
House committee just reissue these
subpoenas after the resolution short
answers they didn't need to the
subpoenas were already fully authorized
in any event even after the resolution
passed the committee's issued subpoenas
to Mick Mulvaney Robert Blair for other
witnesses and the president continued to
block those subpoenas the argument about
a full house vote really is just an
excuse about president Trump's
obstruction the president refused to
comply with the House subpoenas before
the house vote and after the house vote
the only logical explanation is the one
that President Trump gave us all along
he was determined to fight all the
subpoenas because entrust president
Trump's you according to what he said he
can do whatever he wants now that's not
what the constitutional republic
entrusted to us by the founders had in
mind this argument doesn't just imply to
impeachment that would apply to ordinary
oversight investigations and it doesn't
just apply to the house it would also
apply to the Senate by sanctioning the
president's blanket obstruction the
Senate would be curtailing its own
subpoena power in the future as well as
the houses and the oversight obligation
that we have as we now know it would be
permanently altered I yield back
Thank You MS manager mr. chief justice
from Kentucky I have a question to
present to the desk for the house
manager Schiff and for the president's
counsel
you
the presiding officer declines to read
the question as submitted mr. Chief
Justice the senator from Wisconsin mr.
Chief Justice I sent a question to the
desk thank you
the question from Senator Baldwin is
addressed to the house managers given
that the White House Council could not
answer senator Romney's question that
asked for the exact date the president
first ordered the hold on security
assistance to Ukraine
what witness or witnesses could answer
senator Romney's question
Thank You chief justice Thank You
senator for the question you're right
they were not able to directly answer
that question and we believe that there
is a tremendous amount of material out
there in the form of emails text
messages conversation and witness
testimony that could shed additional
light on that including an email from
last summer between mr. Bolton mr. Blair
where we know from witness testimony
this issue was discussed what we do know
is from multiple witnesses Ukrainian
officials knew that President Trump had
placed a hold on security assistance
soon after was ordered in July of 2019
so we we know that not only did US
officials know about it and OMB
communicated about it but the Ukrainians
knew about it as well
we know from former Deputy Foreign
Minister of Ukraine
Elena Zirkle she stated publicly in fact
that the Ukrainian officials knew about
it and had found out about it in July we
also know from the testimony of Laura
Cooper that her staff received two
emails from the State Department on July
25th revealing that the Ukrainian
Embassy was quote asking about security
assistance in quote and that quote the
hill knows about the FMF situation to an
extent and so does the Ukrainian embassy
in quote and that was on July 25th the
same day as president Trump's call with
President Solinsky what we also know is
that career diplomat Catherine Croft
stated that quote she was very surprised
at the effectiveness of my Ukrainian
counterparts diplomatic tradecraft
as in to say they found out very early
on or much earlier than I expected them
to in quote we also know that Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander Alexander Whitman
testified that by mid-august he was
getting questions from Ukrainians about
the status of security assistance so
there is a lot of evidence surrounding
it the administration continues to
obstruct wholly our efforts to get the
emails and correspondence that we have
asked for that obviously can be remedied
by this body with the appropriate
namely a subpoena to ambassador Bolton
to testify and a subpoena to the State
Department and Department of State and
Department of Defense and others to
actually provide that material last
thing I'd like to say is last evening
counsel for the president was asked the
question about why did the the hold for
Ukraine differ from holds in the
northern triangle and other holds like
Afghanistan he provided an explanation
that I'm still trying to wrap my brain
around because he seems to be the only
person in the administration that
actually has an explanation he and as
far as I could tell the explanation was
somewhere along the lines of one was
public and trying to poke public
pressure on the countries in question
and one was not was a private
conversation in a private effort to put
pressure if that were true then of
course there would be plenty of evidence
plenty of emails text messages and other
correspondence within the entire
interagency process that we know is
robust that would illustrate that to be
the case but they have failed to provide
any evidence to corroborate that and let
me finish with this I happen to know
that a lot of people in this chamber a
lot of people in the chamber and the
other side of the Capitol including me
have often described much consternation
about red tape and bureaucracy and in
layers of government that run too slow
and I sometimes share that concern right
that sometimes it takes a long time
there are memos for everything emails
for everything there's paper trails for
everything in this town I think that is
true with respect to this issue and as
time that we actually see that
information so we can get to the the
bottom of what actually happened this
body could get that information Thank
You mr. manager mr. chief justice the
senator from Pennsylvania mr. chief
justice I send a question to the desk on
behalf of myself and Senator sass
mcsalley Crapo Thune young Ernst and
bronc
you
the question from senator Toomey and
other senators is for counsel for the
president given that the election of the
president is one of the most significant
political acts in which we as citizens
engage in our democratic system how much
weight should the Senate give to the
fact that removing the president from
office and disqualifying him from ever
holding future federal office would undo
that Democratic decision and kick the
president off the ballot in this year's
election members of the Senate one of
the concerns that we've raised
throughout this process over the last
several months in going back to the time
when the house was dealing with this in
their various committees is we're in an
election year
there are some in this room that our
days away from the Iowa caucus is taking
place so we're discussing the possible
impeachment and removal of the President
of the United States not only during
election season in the heart of the
election season and I think that this
does a disservice to the American people
again we think the basis upon which this
is moved forward is irregular to say the
least but I do think it complicates the
matter for the American people that we
are literally at the dawn of a new
season of elections I mean we're at that
season now and yet we're talking about
impeaching a president and I want to tie
this into the urgency that was so
prevalent in December with my colleagues
the managers it was so urgent to move
this forward that they had to do it by
mid-december before Christmas because
national security was at stake and then
they waited 33 days to bring it here and
now they're asking you to do all the
investigation although they say they you
know prove their case but still need
more to prove it of course we believe
and I want to be clear here that their
entire process was corrupt from the
beginning and there is putting it on
this body but to do it while the
American people are selecting
candidates for nomination to be the head
of their party to run as president of
the United States some of you in this
very room and to talk about the removal
of a President of the United States I
think that's all part and parcel of the
same pattern and practice of
irregularities that have taken place
with this impeachment proceeding since
the beginning the speaker allowed the
articles to linger it was such a
nationally urgent matter that they could
linger for a month so we think that this
points to the exact problem what's
taking place here and that is my
colleague mr. sepiol Oni has said this
is really taking the vote away from the
American people thank mr. choucas Thank
You counsel the senator from Montana mr.
Chief Justice I send a question to the
desk for the house managers thank you
senator tester asked the house managers
yesterday mr. dersh awit stated quote if
a president does something which he
believes will help him get elected in
the public interest that cannot be the
kind of quid pro quo that results in
impeachment end quote do you believe
there is any limit to the type or scope
of quid pro quo a sitting president
could engage in with the foreign entity
as long as the intent of the sitting
president is to get reelected in what he
or she believes is in the public's best
interest Chief Justice Senator there is
no limiting principle to the argument
that we heard last night from the
president's team that is if there's a
quid pro quo that the President believes
will help him get reelected and he
believes his reelection is in the
national interest then it doesn't matter
how corrupt that quid pro quo is it's
astonishing that on the floor of this
body some would would make that argument
now it didn't begin that way in the
beginning of the president's defense but
what we have seen over the last couple
days is a descent into constitutional
madness because that way madness lies if
we are to accept the premise that a
president essentially can do whatever he
wants engage in whatever quid pro quo he
wants I will give you this if you will
give me that to help me get elected I
will give you military dollars if you
will give me help in my reelection if
you will give me illicit foreign
interference in our election now the
only reason you make that argument is
because you know your client is guilty
and dead to rights that is an argument
made of desperation now what's so
striking to me is almost half a century
ago we had a president
who said well when the president does it
that means it is not illegal that of
course was Richard Nixon Watergate is
now 40 to 50 years behind us have we
learned nothing in the last half century
that we learned nothing at all it seems
like we're back to where we were the
president says it it's not illegal or
Donald Trump's version under Article two
I can do whatever I want or professor
Dershowitz point if it's if the
President believes it helps his
reelection it is therefore in the
national interest you can do whatever he
wants in fact much as we thought that we
progressed post-watergate we enacted
watergate reforms and we tried to
insulate the Justice Department from
interference by the presidency we tried
to put an end to the political abuses of
that Department as much as we thought we
enacted campaign finance reforms we are
right back to where we were a
half-century ago and I would argue we
may be in a worse place because this
time this time that argument may succeed
that argument if the president says it
it can't be illegal failed and Richard
Nixon was forced to resign but that
argument may succeed here now that means
we're not back to where we were we are
worse off than where we are that is the
normalization of lawlessness I would
hope that every American would recognize
that it's wrong to seek foreign help in
an American election that Americans
should decide American elections I would
hope and I believe that every American
understands that and every American
understands that's true for Democratic
presidents and Republican ones I would
hope that we would understand I would
hope that this trial would be one
conducive of the truth the senator asked
what witnesses could shed light
when the president ordered the hold and
why well we know Mick Mulvaney would
that instruction came from OMB you
remember the testimony ambassador Taylor
the shock that went through the National
Security Council and the shock he
experienced in that videoconference when
was first announced and the instruction
was this comes through the president's
chief of staff OMB but it's a direct
order from the president well Mick
Mulvaney knows when that order went into
place and he knows why that order went
into place and he made that statement
publicly which he now wishes to recant
I'm sure he got an earful from the
president after he did but apparently it
doesn't matter none of that matters
because if the president believes it
says the interest it's okay now there
was an argument also well what if it was
a credible reason of course there's no
evidence that this was a credible reason
to investigate for the president's
arrival but Lex it was a credible reason
does that make it right what president
is not going to think he has a credible
reason to investigate his opponent what
President is going to think he doesn't
have a credible reason or wouldn't be
able to articulate one or come up with
some fig leaf
they compounded the dangerous argument
that they made that no quid pro quo is
to corrupt if you think it'll help your
election they compounded it by saying
and if what you want is targeting your
rival it's even more legitimate that way
madness lies justice
the senator from North Dakota I sent a
question to the desk on behalf of myself
and senator young thank you
thank you the question from Senator
Kramer and Jung is for the council for
the president manager shift regularly
states that if the president is innocent
he would agree to all of the witnesses
and documents that the managers want is
the president the first innocent
defendant not to waive his rights
mr. Chief Justice senator thank you for
that question because the answer is
obviously no the president is not the
first innocent defendant who decided not
to waive his rights and I think it is
striking and shocking that one of the
arguments that has been repeatedly
deployed by the house managers
throughout these proceedings
we heard manager Nadler say only the
guilty hide evidence only the guilty
don't respond to subpoenas and manager
Nadler excuse me managers shift say that
this is not the way innocent people act
well of course that's contrary to the
very spirit of our American justice
system where people have rights and
asserting those rights cannot be
interpreted as an indication of guilt
that is expressly forbidden by the laws
and by the Constitution and the Supreme
Court explained in Bordenkircher versus
Hayes the case that's cited in our trial
memorandum that the very idea of
punishing someone which is what the
house managers are attempting to do here
with their obstruction of Congress
charge to say that if the president
insists on the constitutional
prerogatives of his office if the
president insists that like virtually
every president at least six since Nixon
and some going beyond further back to
that he's going to assert the immunity
of his senior advisors to compel
congressional testimony if he's going to
assert those rights grounded in the
separation of powers and essential for
protecting constitutionally based
executive branch confidentiality
interests we're gonna call that
obstruction of Congress and impeach him
and it's this fundamental theme running
throughout both their obstruction charge
and their arguments generally here that
if the president stands on his
constitutional rights if he tries to
protect the institutional prerogatives
of his office which he is duty-bound to
do for future occupants of that office
that's somehow an indication of guilt
and shows that he ought to be impeached
and that's fundamentally antithetic
to the American system of justice and to
our principles of due process to our
principles of acknowledging that rights
can be defended that rights exist to be
defended and asserting those rights
cannot be treated either as something
punishable or as evidence of guilt and
there would be a long line of past
precedents presidents excuse me as
professor Dershowitz pointed out there
are a lot of presidents who have been
accused of abuse of power there'd also
be a long line of precedence who could
have been impeached for quote-unquote
obstruction of Congress if every time a
president insisted upon the prerogatives
of the office of the presidency and
insisted on defending the separation of
powers that could be treated as it's
something impeachable and his evidence
of guilt President Obama himself refused
to turn over a lot of documents to the
house in the Fast and Furious
investigation his Attorney General was
held in contempt but no one's thought
that that was an impeachable offense so
the concept of saying that when the
president asserts constitutionally
grounded Prag gives of his office that
is evidence of guilt is a completely
bogus assertion it's contrary to all the
principles of our american justice
system and the fundamental principles of
fairness and it ought to be rejected by
this body thank you Thank You counsel
mr. Chief Justice the senator from
Alabama Thank You mr. chief justice I
send a question to the desk thank you
Senator Jones's question is for the
house managers aside from the houses
constitutional impeachment Authority
please identify specifically which
provision or provisions if any in the
house rules or a House Resolution
authorized the subpoenas issued by the
House committees prior to the passage of
House Resolution 660
lists the subpoenas that were issued
after House Resolution
senator we will compile the list we
don't have accessible at the moment and
an answer to a question oh we do have it
we do have let me just if I could and
specifically the subpoenas that went out
after the passage of the House
Resolution were subpoena to John
Eisenberg to subpoena to Bryan McCormack
Robert Blair Michael Ellis Preston Wells
Griffith and Mick Mulvaney but let me
underscore something that my colleague
manager Lofgren had to say and let me
break this down if I can in very
practical terms what is the practical
import of what counsel for the president
would argue and it is this lets say that
a Democrat is elected in November and
let's say that any one of you that chair
a committee in the Senate determine that
you think that the next president has
engaged in something questionable maybe
even some wrongdoing and you begin an
investigation and I would imagine that
your Senate rules like our house rules
in its house rule 10 senator that has
the specific language authorizing the
issuance of subpoenas as a part of our
normal oversight responsibilities that
power didn't exist at the time of
Watergate so they had to have a separate
resolution but that house rule passed
each session empowers us to issue
subpoenas as committee chairs as part of
our oversight jurisdiction so there you
are Democratic president your chair you
start to do oversight you issue
subpoenas you start to learn more and
what you learn becomes more and more
concerning and you issue more subpoenas
and the administration effort to cover
up their misconduct says we're not going
to comply with any of your subpoenas
we're gonna fight all subpoenas and they
come up with one bad faith excuse after
another as to why they don't have to
comply and as you investigate further
and you're able to overcome the wall of
obstruction then you begin an
impeachment inquiry and that leads the
passage of yet another resolution they
would argue to you that all the work you
did before you determine that it merited
potential impeachment must
thrown out that they were perfectly
empowered to obstruct you in your
oversight responsibilities that you must
begin with your conclusion and you must
begin with the conclusion that you are
prepared to peach the president before
you issue a single subpoena otherwise
they can say whatever you did before you
got to that place should be thrown out
now we did not have the Justice
Department do the initial investigation
here why because bill Barr turned it
down the same attorney general general
mentioned that July 25th call said
there's nothing to see here so there was
no DOJ investigation there was no
special counsel investigation
it wasn't as if someone like Ken Starr
handed us a package and said here's the
evidence now you can take up a
resolution and a peaceful resolution
because we have done the investigative
work now we had to do that work
ourselves and they would have you
believe that any subpoena you issue as a
part of your oversight responsibility
that down the road reveals evidence that
leads you to embark on an appeasement
inquiry must be disregarded that cannot
and is not the law it would render the
oversight function meaningless Court
after Court that has looked at the
Congress's power to issue subpoenas have
all reached the same conclusion and that
is if you have the power to legislate
you have the power to oversee here we
have a violation of the impoundment
Control Act that is Congress passes
military spending the president doesn't
spend it he gives no reason he keeps it
a secret we're investigating that that
can't be more squarely within the
oversight power of Congress to find out
why aid we appropriated was not going
out the door they would say you can't
look into that unless you're prepared to
impeach the president and announce it
first and that's the import of that
argument it would [ __ ] your oversight
capacity and without your oversight
capacity your legislative capacity is
crippled that's the real-world import of
this legal window-dressing they would
strip you of your ability to do
meaningful oversight and particularly
here where we're talking about
misconduct of an impeachable kind and
character it would mean that a president
can obstruct their own investigation and
if you need any evidence of their bad
faith of which is abundant the shifting
and springing rationalizations and
explanations when we had corey
lewandowski in the intelligence
committee
they said that under instructions to the
white house he wouldn't answer questions
because he might they might claim
executive privilege now this was someone
who never worked for the executive they
made the claim they might use executive
privilege I'm sorry my time up time is
expired thank you
the senator from Texas mr. Chief Justice
I sent a question to the desk on behalf
of myself and senators Holly and grant
thank you
the question from senator Cruz along
with senators Holly and Graham is for
both sides the counsel for the president
and the house managers yesterday
manager Demmings refused to answer
whether joe biden sought any legal
advice concerning his conflict of
interest on Purisima the corrupt array
Ukranian company that was paying his son
hunter 1 million dollars per year USA
Today reported that when asked about it
Vice President Biden said excuse me
quote he hadn't spoken to his son hunter
Biden about his overseas business end
quote that account was contradicted by
hunter Biden who told the New Yorker
that he told his father about Purisima
and quote dad said I hope you know what
you're doing and I said I do
why do Joe and hunter Biden's stories
conflict did the House ask either one
that question the White House Council
goes first
you heard our answer I'm sorry
Chief Justice senators senators you
heard our answer regarding that
yesterday but it is very interesting
that he said he never spoke to his son
about overseas dealings his son said
different things Joe Biden was the point
man for Ukraine investigating at the
time Ukrainians were a corrupt company
burry smih and stole chef's key its
owner oleg arc who by all media accounts
we've discussed was extremely corrupt
hunter Biden is paid eighty three
thousand dollars a month a month to sit
on that board with no experience in
energy no experience in the Ukraine
doesn't speak the language and we
clearly know that he had a very fancy
Job Description and he did none of those
things he attended one or two board
meetings one in Monaco and then he went
on a fishing trip with Joe Biden's
family in Norway the entire time Joe
Biden knows that Joe Biden knows that
this oleg art is corrupt everyone knows
that there are news reports everywhere
no one will dispute that in fact it
raised eyebrows worldwide but the vice
president by his account never once
asked his son to leave the board we
wouldn't be sitting here if he did he
never asked his son to leave the board
instead he started investigating the
prosecutor who was going after burry
smih and this corrupt oligarch who they
say was corrupt even by oligarchs
standards who had fled the country fled
the country living in Monaco he does not
ask him to leave the board he does the
opposite in 2015 what does he do we know
by reports he has close contact with
President poroshenko he travels to
Ukraine twice he links it to the fire he
links the aide to the firing same thing
in 2016 at a White House meeting links
the aide to the firing of the prosecutor
calls him four times in the eight days
up to leading to the prosecutor the
the prosecutor investigating hunter
Biden yet he never says that all cases
closed days before Biden leaves office
he jokes to poroshenko that he may have
to call him every couple weeks to check
in Hunter body stays on that board for
three years three years then we hear the
video of Joe Biden bragging about firing
the prosecutor linking it to ade then we
have the six minute phone call mr. chief
justice oh there's I'm sorry the house
managers have two and a half minutes
there's a chief justice and two our
senators senators thank you so much for
that question I know you have asked
about a conversation between a father
and his son and what I can tell you
probably like just about everybody in
this chamber they're probably some
conversations that I can't repeat to you
about my conversations with my son so I
don't know the answer to your question
senator what that exact conversation was
but what I can tell you is this if we
are serious about why we are here and I
have no reason to doubt that we are if
we were serious about seeking the truth
because the truth matters not just for
those who have aid the price in our
history to form them a more perfect
union and protect our democracy but it's
important for our future and in this
case if we were serious about that then
I can tell you this that we are serious
then about hearing from fact witnesses
looking at the Biden's no matter how
many times we called their name we have
no evidence to point to the fact that
either Biden has anything at all to tell
us about
the president shaking down a foreign
power to help him cheat in the next
election the precious election trying to
steal each individual in this country's
vote I don't believe either Biden has
any information about that but let me
tell you who I think does maybe we
should call ambassador Bolton if we're
serious about the truth maybe we should
call him because we have a good idea
about what he might say or what about
mr. Mulvaney who had day-to-day contact
with the principal in our investigation
the President of the United States
that's not good enough well what about
the question was asked about when did we
know or when did the president first put
the whole on well we do have reports
that say on June 19th of 2019 Mr Blair
personally instructed the director of
OMB to hold up security assistance from
Ukraine over a month before the infamous
July 25th call so manager Thank You mr.
chief justice
mr. Chief Justice I send a question the
senator from Nevada I send a question to
the desk thank you
the question from Senator Rosen is
addressed to the house managers over the
course of your arguments you have tried
to make a case that the president put
his personal interests over those of the
nation risking our national security in
the process what precedent do you
believe the president's actions set for
future presidents
mr. Chief Justice senator thank you for
that question it's one that I've wanted
to answer for some time now you've heard
me speak before about some of my
personal experience and service to the
country and one thing that that
experience has taught me is that we are
strong not just because of this service
and the sacrifice of our men and women
in uniform which is extreme and appear
in all of its sense in something that I
think everybody in this chamber actually
appreciates and respects but we are also
strong because we have friends we are
strong because America doesn't go it
alone you know when I was in Iraq and
Afghanistan I worked frequently with
Afghan army partners Iraqi army partners
and others not because it was important
but because it was essential that we
couldn't accomplish the mission without
it but if those partners feel like our
policies what we say publicly don't
matter if they feel like we are not a
reliable and predictable partner if they
feel like the American handshake isn't
worth anything then they will not stand
by us they will not stand by us and for
over seventy years since the end of
World War two the partnerships the
Alliance's that we have built that we
have strived to create that is ushered
in an unprecedented period of peace and
prosperity throughout the world will
start to fray because the American
handshake will not matter Ukraine it
started to learn that our 68,000 troops
throughout Europe deserve better because
every day they get up and they do their
job the job that we have asked them to
do
and they rely on our consistency our
predictability they rely on the interest
being in the national interest not the
whims in the personal interest of the
president whether that be President
Trump or any other president it will
continue to call into question our
broader alliances and it will send a
message of the American handshake
doesn't matter we have a slide that
shows the evolution of some of the
different arguments that we've seen on
the other side that I think is important
to see Russia if you're listening I hope
you're able to find the 30,000 emails
that are missing I think you will
probably be rewarded mightily by our
press let's see if that happened
campaign this time around if foreigners
if Russia if China if someone else
offers you information an opponent
should they accept it or should they
call the FBI I think maybe you do both I
think you might want to listen I don't
there's nothing wrong with listening if
somebody called from a country Norway we
have information on your opponent oh I
think I'd want to hear if you want that
kind of interference in our elections
it's not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it let's
move to the third excerpt that I
mentioned related to Vice President
Biden and it says the other thing
there's a lot of talk about Biden's son
this is President Trump speaking that
Biden stopped the prosecution and a lot
of people want to find out about that so
whatever you can do with the attorney
general would be great Biden went around
bragging that he stopped the prosecution
so if you can look into it it sounds
horrible well I would think that if they
were honest about it that sort of major
investigation into the Viking it's a
very simple answer
if we feel this corruption like I feel
there was in the 2016 campaign there was
tremendous corruption against me if we
feel this corruption we have a right to
go to a foreign country and by the way
likewise China just started
investigation into the budget because
what happened in China is just about as
bad as what happened with with Ukraine
the deserve to know what happened the
American people deserve to know when
they go to bed tonight
that there's a president that has their
interests in mind that will put the
national security of the country above
his own political self-interest the
American people deserve answers and yes
it is still a good time to call
ambassador bolt into testifying Thank
You mr. manager the senator from Ohio
mr. Chief Justice I send a question to
the desk on behalf of myself senators
Toomey Cornyn Crapo Ernst and Moran
thank you
the question from Senator Portman and
the other senators is for the counsel
for the president I have been surprised
to hear the house managers repeatedly
invoke constitutional law professor
Jonathan Turley
to support their position including
playing a part of a video of him isn't
it true that Professor Turley opposed
this impeachment in the house and has
also said that abuse of power is
exceedingly difficult to prove alone
without any accompanying criminal
allegation abuse of power has never been
the sole basis for a presidential
impeachment and was not proven in this
case mr. chief justice senators thank
you for that question
and that is exactly correct professor
Turley was very critical of the entire
process in the house and of the charges
that the house the House Democrats were
considering here both the abuse of power
charge and the obstruction charge and he
explained that this was a rushed process
that had not adequately pursued an
investigation that as the the Senators
point out in the question abuse of power
is an exceedingly difficult theory to
use to impeach a president and it has
never been used without alleging
violations of the law and I think that
in the discussions we've had over the
past week and a half we've pointed
excuse me pointed that out multiple
times every presidential impeachment in
our history including even the Nixon
impeachment proceedings which didn't
actually lead to an impeachment have
used charges that include specific
violations of the law in the criminal
law Andrew Johnson was charged mostly in
counts that involved violation of the
tenure of office Act which the Congress
had specifically made punishable by fine
and imprisonment and even rode into the
statute that violation would constitute
either a high crime or high misdemeanor
but one of those terms to make it clear
that it was going to be
used to trigger an impeachment in the
proceedings in the Nixon impeachment
inquiry each of the articles of
impeachment there except for the the
obstruction of Congress charge was sort
of treated separately on the obstruction
theory included specific violations of
law there were specific violations
alleged in the second article of
impeachment which is often sort of
referred to loosely as the abuse of
power article it wasn't actually titled
abuse of power it didn't charge abuse of
power the specifications there were
violations law violating the
constitutional rights of citizens
violating the laws governing executive
branch agencies unlawful electronic
surveillance using the CIA and others
specific violations of law and clearly
in the Clinton impeachment President
Clinton was impeached for perjury and
obstruction of justice those are crimes
and well professor Turley does not take
the view that a crime is necessarily
required he pointed out here that there
was not nearly a sufficient basis and
not nearly a sufficient record compiled
in the House of Representatives to
justify an abuse of power charge he also
was very critical of the obstruction of
Congress theory and he pointed out that
it would be an abuse of power by
Congress under these circumstances where
Congress has simply demanded information
gotten a refusal from the executive
branch based on constitutionally based
prerogatives of the executive a refusal
to provide that information then to
simply go straight to impeachment
without going through the accommodations
process without considering contempt
without going to the courts that was
Professor Turley's view how
incrementally the House of
Representatives would have to proceed if
they were going to try to reach
ultimately some theory of obstruction of
Congress so to cite Professor Turley it
is true that in his academic writing and
in his testimony he did not adopt the
view that you must have a crime and only
a crime
as the charge for an article of
impeachment he still thought that
neither of the articles of impeachment
here could be justified or sufficient or
could be used to impeach the president
both the abuse of power article and the
obstruction article
so taking snippets out of what he said
really does an injustice to the totality
of his testimony because the totality of
his testimony was entirely against what
the house ended up doing here thank you
the senator from Ohio mr. chief justice
on behalf of senator Wyden and myself
I send a question to the desk for the
house managers Thank You senator Brown
and Wyden asked the following question
for the house managers during
yesterday's proceedings the president's
counsel failed to give an adequate
response to a question related to
whether acceptance of information
provided by a foreign country to a
political campaign or candidate would
constitute a violation of the law and
whether offers of such information
should be reported to the FBI FBI
director Christopher Ray who was
appointed by President Trump has said
quote if any public official or member
of any campaign is contacted by any
nation state or anybody acting on behalf
of a nation state about influencing or
interfering with our election then that
is something that the FBI would want to
know about end quote and we'd like to
make sure people tell us information
promptly so that we can take the
appropriate steps to protect the
American people
end quote if President Trump remains in
office what signal does that send to
other countries intent on interfering
with our elections in the future and
what might we expect from
those countries and the president
mr. Chief Justice distinguished members
of the Senate thank you for that
question take the last part first it
would send a terrible message to
autocrats and dictators and enemies of
democracy and the free world for the
president and his team to essentially
put out there for all to consume that
it's acceptable in the United States to
solicit foreign interference in our free
and fair elections or accept political
dirt simply to try to cheat in the next
election I was certainly shocked by the
comments from the president's deputy
White House Council yesterday right here
on the floor when he said I think the
idea that any information that happens
to come from overseas is necessarily
campaign interference is a mistake no
it's wrong it's wrong in the United
States of America he also added
information that is credible that
potentially shows wrongdoing by someone
that happens to be running for office if
it's credible information is relevant
for the voters to know to be able to
decide on who is the best candidate this
is not a Banana Republic
it's the Democratic Republic of the
United States of America it's wrong
now the single most important lesson
that we learned from 2016 was that
nobody should seek or welcome foreign
interference in our elections but now we
have this president and his counsel
essentially saying it's okay it is not
okay it strikes at the very heart of
what the framers of the Constitution
were concerned about abuse of power
betrayal by the president of his oath of
office corrupting the integrity of our
the
amok ricean are free and fair elections
by entangling oneself with foreign
powers that's at the heart of what the
framers of the Constitution were
concerned about don't just trust me we
have several folks who have made this
observation the FBI director the Trump
FBI director said that the FBI would
want to know about any attempt that
foreign election interference and the
chair of the Federal Elections
Commission also issued a statement
reiterating the view of US law
enforcement she said in part let me make
something 100% clear to the American
people and anyone running for office it
is illegal for any person to solicit
accept or receive anything of value from
a foreign national in connection with a
US election this is not a novel concept
election intervention from foreign
governments has been considered
unacceptable since the beginning of our
nation it is wrong it is corrupt it is
lawless it's an abuse of power
it's impeachable and it should lead to
the removal of President Donald John
Trump Thank You mr. manager mr. chief
justice
senator from Missouri I send to the desk
a question on my own behalf and on
behalf of Senator Lee thank you
the question from senators Holley and
Lee is for counsel for the president
United States federal courts have held
most prominently in the legal Javitch
case that it is not unlawful for a
public official to condition his
official acts on official acts performed
by another public officer is there any
application to the allegations against
President Trump
mr. Chief Justice senators thank you for
that question
I think an important threshold point to
make here is that we're not even in the
realm of exchanging official acts
because there's been no proof of a quid
pro quo here we're not in the realm of a
situation where there's one official act
being traded for another I think that
we've gone through the evidence that
makes it quite clear that both with
respect to an office meeting with the
president of bilateral meeting and with
respect to the temporary pause on the
Security Assistance the evidence just
doesn't stack up to show the president
Trump linked either of those both took
place the meeting and the release of the
aid without Ukrainians doing anything
announcing or beginning any
investigations there's nothing in the
transcript linking them as a quid pro
quo
the Ukrainians didn't even know that the
there had been a temporary pause on the
aid and I could go on with the list of
points on that I think if there were any
application hypothetically it would come
in the realm of the fact that in foreign
policy there are situations where there
can be situations where one government
wants some action from another and wants
that action from another in a way that
will condition other policies of one
country you can say we would like you
and this happens for example with the
northern triangle countries we want you
to do more to stop the flow of illegal
immigration we're going to be
conditioning some of our policies
towards you unless and until you start
doing a better job stopping the flow of
illegal immigration because it's a real
problem on our southern border that
happens all the time and when there's
something legitimate to look into there
could be a situation where the United
States would say you've got to do better
on corruption you've got to do better on
these specific areas of corruption or
we're not going to be able to keep have
the same relationship with you one
example like that I believe we've
pointed out that aid was held up to
Afghanistan President Trump held up aid
to Afghanistan specifically because of
concerns about corruption and in
situations like that there'd be nothing
wrong whatsoever with conditioning one
policy approach on a foreign country
modifying their policy to be more in
line to a tune more directly to US
interest that's part of what foreign
policy is all about and that could arise
in the situation of even investigations
and I think it's interesting to point
out that in May of 2018 three Democratic
senators sent a letter to the then
prosecutor in Ukraine suggesting that
we've heard some things that you might
not be cooperating with the mauler
investigation and there is sort of an
implicit indication behind the letter
that there's not going to be as much
support for Ukraine this is something
that's important you've got to be
helping with that election and there's
nothing wrong with encouraging the
prosecutor general to assist with
something that's important to the United
States that's part of foreign policy
happens all the time so to the extent
that that case the the Blagojevich case
is relevant I think is in the general
concept that were there some linkage
between we want your country to pursue
these policies it's going to affect our
policies towards you that's entirely
legitimate that's not something that is
a violation of any law or is improper
but it going to come back to the point
that here there is no proof of that
linkage there is no proof that there was
any sort of as we've come to call it
quid pro quo in this case thank you
Thank You counsel
the senator from Washington mr. Chief
Justice I sent a question to the desk
thank you
Senator Cantwell's
is for the house managers in his opening
remarks
chairman Schiff said the Ukraine scheme
was expansive and involved many people
is there any evidence that acting White
House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
secretary of state Pompeo attorney
general bar or anyone on the outside
were involved in this scheme to withhold
military aid or obstruction of Congress
mr. Chief Justice and Senator thank you
so much for that question
if we remember ambassador somnolence
testimony where he said everyone was in
the loop but we don't just have to take
his word for it during his hearing mr.
Solomon discussed a July 19th email he
sent to the president's top aides
including secretary Mike Pompeo acting
chief of staff Mick Mulvaney mr.
Mulvaney senior advisor Robert Blair
secretary Rick Perry and Brian McCormick
secretary Perry's chief of staff and we
should at least start with if we're
serious about getting to the truth
issuing a subpoena for US State
Department emails if you'll pay
attention to the slide in the email
silence stated quote I talked to
Solinsky just now he is prepared to
receive POTUS call will assure him that
he intends to run a fully transparent
investigation and will turn over every
stone he would greatly appreciate a call
prior to Sunday so that he can put out
some media about a friendly and
productive call no details mr. Mulvaney
in the email acknowledges receipt and
responds shortly I asked the NSC to set
up the call for tomorrow six days before
President Trump now-infamous July 25th
call in which he told president
szalinski to conduct investigations into
the bodies and the 2016 election mr.
Sandlin sent an email to the president's
top aides
updating them on the status of the
scheme again quote everyone was in the
loop on August 11
ambassador Solomon email mr. Brett ball
to ask him to brief Secretary Pompeo on
a statement he was negotiating with
president said Linsky with the aim of
quote making the boss happy the boss
being the president enough to authorize
the investigation
ambassador Solomon wrote to mr. Brett
ball and I quote Kurt and I negotiated a
statement from Z mr. Solinsky to be
delivered for our review in a day or two
the contents will hopefully make the
boss happy enough to authorize an
invitation and he's talking about the
invitation for a White House oval office
meeting which we know was much more
critical important than a sideline
meeting at the UN yet further evidence
and I quote everyone was in the loop
Attorney General bar reportedly
responded at some point if there was a
New York Times article that was done and
a returnee general bar responded to that
article by stating that he was aware of
DOJ investigations into some countries
and that he was concerned President
Trump was giving world leaders the
impression he had undue influence over
what would ordinarily be independent
investigations he cited conversations
the President had with leaders of Turkey
and China further demonstrating that
there was concern about the president
abusing the power of his office for
personal political reasons again it
proves that everybody was in the loop
and we should want to subpoena and
review those emails involving the State
Department and others
thank you mrs. manager mr. chief justice
senator from South Dakota I sent a
question of the desk on behalf of myself
and senators Moran Danes Ernst Scott of
Florida and Crapo thank you
Thank You senator thune and the other
senators asked the council for the
president on March 6 2019 Speaker Nancy
Pelosi said quote impeachment is so
divisive to the country that unless
there's something so compelling and
overwhelming and bipartisan I don't
think we should go down that path
because it divides the country end quote
Alexander Hamilton also warned in
Federalist 65 against the quote
persecution of an intemperate or
designing majority in the House of
Representatives with respect to
impeachment in evaluating the case
against the president should the Senate
take into account the partisan nature of
the impeachment proceedings in the house
thank you mr. Chief Justice members of
the Senate absolutely you should take
that into account that's dispositive
that should end it based on the
statements that we heard the last time
from our friends on the Democratic side
that's a reason why you shouldn't have
an impeachment speaker Pelosi was right
when she said that unfortunately she
didn't follow her own advice
we've never been in a situation where we
have the impeachment of a president in
an election year
with the goal of removing the president
from the ballot as I've said before that
is the most massive election
interference we've ever witnessed its
domestic election interference it's
political election election interference
and it's wrong they don't talk about the
horrible consequences to our country of
doing that but they would be terrible
they would tear us apart for generations
and the American people wouldn't accept
it let me address in that context the
importance of the vote for their inquiry
which also had bipartisan opposition
now they said well we were fine when
when Speaker Pelosi announced it we
didn't need a vote the subpoenas were
authorized then why did they have a vote
they had a vote because they understood
they had a big problem that they needed
to fix but what's more important about
the vote than the procedural issue the
important thing about the vote is that
if you're going to start an impeachment
investigation particularly on in an
election year there needs to be
political accountability to the American
people you can't just go have a press
conference if you're going to say that
the Botes of the American people need to
be disallowed that all of the ballots
need to be torn up then at the very
least you need to be accountable to your
home district for that decision and now
they are and now they are and if the
American people decide if they're
allowed to vote if the American people
decide that they don't like what's
happened here that they don't like the
constitutional violations that have
happened that they don't like the attack
on a successful president for purely
partisan political purposes then they
can do something about it and they can
throw them out that's why it votes
important but we should never even
consider removing the name of a
president from the ballot on a purely
partisan basis in an election year
important I'll say it's important for
that reason alone and for the interest
of uniting our country it must be
rejected Thank You mr. chief justice
Thank You counsel mr. Chief Jeff
Oh senator from Rhode Island
mr. Chief Justice I send a question to
the desk on behalf of Senator Duckworth
sander Harris and myself for the house
managers and for the president's counsel
thank you
the question from Senator Reid and the
other senators is for both parties
beginning with the house managers it has
been reported that President Trump does
not pay Rudy Giuliani his personal
attorney for his services
can you explain who has paid for rudy
giuliani's legal fees international
travel and other expenses in his
capacity as president Trump's attorney
and representative
the short answer the question is I don't
know who's paying Rudy Giuliani's fees
and if he is not being paid by the
President to conduct this domestic
political errand for which he has
devoted so much time if other clients
are paying and subsidizing his work in
that respect it raises profound
questions questions that we can't answer
at this point but there are some answers
that we do know as he has acknowledged
he's not there doing foreign policy so
when counsel for the president says this
is a policy dispute you can impeach a
president over policy what Rudy Giuliani
was engaged in by his own admission has
nothing to do with policy it has nothing
to do with policy and let me mention one
other thing about this scheme that
Giuliani was orchestrating and the
consequence of the argument that they
would make that it's quid pro quos are
just fine let's say Rudy Giuliani does
another errand for the president this
time an errand in China and he says to
the Chinese we will give you a favorable
deal with respect to Chinese farmers as
opposed to American farmers we will
betray the American farmer in the trade
deal but here's what we want the quid
pro quo is we want you to do an
investigation of the Biden's you know
the one the one the president has been
calling for they would say that's okay
they would say that's a quid pro quo to
help his reelection he can betray the
American farmer that's okay that's their
argument where does that argument lead
us that's exactly the kind of domestic
corrupt political errand that Rudy
Giuliani was doing gratis
without payment at least not payment
apparently from the president so who's
paying the freight for it well I don't
know who's directly paying the freight
for it but I can tell you the whole
country is paying the freight for it
because there are leaders around the
world who are watching this and they're
saying the American presidency is open
for business
this president wants our help and if we
have
them he will be grateful he will be
grateful is that the kind of message we
want to send to the rest of the world
that's the result of normalizing
lawlessness of the kind that Rudy
Giuliani was engaged in well thank you
I'm sorry your time has expired
council came out of the manager's mouth
open for business I'll tell you who was
open for business
you know know who was open for business
when the vice president of the United
States who was charged by the then
President of the United States with
developing policies to avoid and assist
in removing corruption from Ukraine and
his son was on the board of a company
that was under investigation for Ukraine
and you're concerned about what Rudy
Giuliani the president's lawyer was
doing when he was over trying to
determine what was going on in Ukraine
and by the way it's a little bit
interesting to me and my colleague the
deputy white House Counsel referred to
this it's a little bit ironic to me that
you're gonna be questioning
conversations with foreign governments
about investigations with when three of
you three members of the Senate senator
Menendez senator Leahy and Senator
Durbin sent a letter that read something
quickly like this these were they wrote
the letter to the prosecutor general of
Ukraine they said they're advocates
talking about the congressman they're
strong advocates for robust and close
relationship with Ukraine and we believe
that our cooperation should extend to
such legal matters regardless of
politics and their concern was ongoing
investigations and whether the Muller
team was getting appropriate appropriate
responses from Ukraine regarding
investigations of what the President of
the United States and you're asking
about whether foreign investigations are
appropriate I think it answers itself
Thank You counsel mr. Chief Justice the
senator from Oklahoma Chief Justice I
sent a question the desk on behalf of
myself senator Ernst in senator Crapo
thank you
the question from Senator Lankford and
the other senators is for the counsel
for the president house managers have
described any delay in military aid and
State Department funds to Ukraine in
2019 as a cause to believe there was a
secret scheme or quid pro quo by the
president in 2019
86% of the DoD funds were obligated to
Ukraine in September but in 2018 67
percent of the funds were obligated in
September and in 2017 73 percent of the
funds were obligated in September in the
State Department the funds were
obligated September 30 in 2019 but they
were obligated September 28 in 2018 each
year the vast majority of the funds were
obligated in the final month or days of
the fiscal year was there excuse me was
there a national security risk to
Ukraine or the United States from the
funds going out at the end of September
in the two previous years did it weaken
our relationship with Ukraine because
the vast majority of our aid was
released in September each of the last
three years mr. chief justice
senators thank you for that question and
the short straightforward answer is
there was no Jeopardy to the national
security interest of the United States
from the timing of the release of this
month
if it will be a big change the big
change hopefully they come in they come
up with something decent for everybody
you know so wait everybody can be happy
no more I don't really bother too much
about latency to be
I'm looking for water what's going to
happen like she thinks gonna happen
goodness
just relax I mean I feel like a yeah I
feel like a friend as well I mean I'm I
work in the French Cantera I'm really
representative of French control in
London so what is it London or exiting
is it that is it a British citizen is it
a so I feel like an under Maria anyway
is difficult to live in London the winds
have very expensive the travel
everything even the food now is a bit
too expensive and the the salami where
they give us no real a half so I hope
after breakfast if they were gonna
increase a bit small the wages that
would happen we have to approach
everyone with respect everyone is
different we come just like coach other
person you judge them no many people
come in like anything oh I'm on my own
country end up as long as you want to
work and work do your stuff legal then
still come and silky irregular life you
just have to be like this for example
that all of us come from Portugal for
arts your stuff evening everything like
what you say I'd say that I'm not scared
I'm neutral about it like we will see
what it's
[Music]